[Music]  [Music]  they must be from California it's gonna  be alright just call me the one that  looks the loneliest and speaking song  sentences hello my name is Ann short for  Henry self at this Punk do more time  tonight  your people do ordinary day we do what  we want have you no restriction  that was the future I slept at his house  and met his mom sorry it's my first time  at this it's taking longer than I  expected  and we engaged in incomplete sexual  activity  [Music]  she's not my mother I think they  participate in some bizarre sex rituals  no how do you know that I just don't see  happening you have less than 24 hours to  rectify the situation you're in extreme  danger we have to leave now  Sam needs hope we'll need backup  we may cut this planet up royally but at  least when alive we like to eat we like  to dance fall in love and we try and fix  what our parents screwed up are you  locked with me  [Music]